hallo mein name ist luca und faktisch
bestimmt die so balu gerade so aufgeregt
ist er sich zum freund endlich die
dritte letztlich selbst verstanden ihr
wollt ihr könnt ihr euch noch an die
letzte folge energy sagt dummkopf und
einfach nichts auf die kette kriegt hat
sitzt sitzt sitzt sitzt sitzt merkt ihr
den cheat doch einfach aber jetzt freund
den sie gerade
ich saß ihr halt echt lockert drei
stunden und habe die ganze zeit einfach
gesagt ehrlich ich habe dazu sogar was
auf twitter gepostet aber gut bei lulu
hat einen trick gelernt notiere das
soeben erlernte kommando das heißt ich
schreibe hier jetzt in sich schreibt das
sogar in cap vor allem eine titel man
kämpfen damit der basta das lernt ich
kann den eigentlich gar nicht passen
guckt euch mal an wie süß der jetzt
solltest du dich vergewissern dass baidu
den gelernten trägt auch wirklich
ausführen kann rufe den namen von balu
damit der hund zu dir kommt sobald balu
von ihr steht spricht das neu gelernte
kommando aus zögere nur nichts ballo
ballo ballo ballo sitz sitzt sitzt sitzt
sitz sitz sitz sitzt er scheint nicht so
recht laufen oder pass gut auf damit er
richtig trainiert [ __ ] you nintendogs
neuer dummes micro nicht funktioniert
ich will einfach endlich mal diese ganze
château de ich habe gerade mal sonne
datei angelegt und zwar microphone
sample wo rein theoretisch ist
mit dem sample ich habe es jetzt einfach
so gemacht weil dieses blöde mir raum
ein drucker ist die ganze zeit schon
augen das blöde micro funktioniert beim
einen emulator nicht deswegen habe ich
einen sound sample nacht mit mono
unkomprimiert als wfd www habe ich das
aufgenommen wo ich sitz gesagt habe dass
da reingeschrieben jetzt keine bestimmte
tastenkombination drücken dann sagt man
computer sitzt das hört sich zwar für
uns zu einer zwischen nicht sagen aber
balu rettet die schlimmste nachricht des
tages
da er nun gelernt hat zu sitzen kannst
du auch andere kommandos probieren
bachmann und nun viel spaß und einem
neuen leben mit balu viel glück auf
diese nachricht habe ich gewartet
er macht hat platzwarte dafür habe ich
mich auch extra ein kommando angelegt
das heißt wir gehen wieder in konflikt
und jetzt können wir nämlich rein
theoretisch hier draufklicken ob du
passt da durfte nicht weg und jetzt
machst du platz genau da macht er platz
und jetzt will ich das mit diesem hund
kam es zu einfach nicht arbeiten so als
ob es auch ein trick gibt diese strikte
mit den jetzt hier seinen arsch zu was
soll das denn ich will mit dir
und jetzt macht platz war lukom leg dich
einfach hin ich will die platz
beibringen kommen so richtig in wallung
bitte hätte ich einfach ja genau so und
jetzt platz okay fliegend webling bleibt
liegen bleibt doch liegen du dummkopf
warum steckt mitten in der nacht
ja man nur als ein trick gelernt ist
platz in ordnung ja platz ist in ordnung
speichervorgang bitte schaltet das gerät
nicht aus balu lernte platz freust du
dich balu alles klar
hier können wir uns anschauen was für
weil ich weiß nicht was du da oben
wieder macht ich glaube der
spielcharakter hund weil du kannst du
dich mal einmal benehmen wie ihn
vernünftig macht er da kannst du dir das
befinden des bundes anschauen und zwar
das ist bei lulu der ist männlich dann
hat man das auch geklärt ist ein shiba
inu der trainer ist die job
rudolf hug ist jopie ob gemeinsame zeit
29 minuten
das heißt wenn ihr hier sagt luca den
videos hier vier minuten fünf minuten im
fabrik sei gar keine zeit da 29 minuten
habe ich schon mit dem fahrrad da seht
ihr mal wie lange der schüttelt sich
darum erstmal fell sauber hungrig und
durstig mottaki wir müssen wir
vielleicht mehr väter nehmen hamelow hwc
nicht einmal das wird sogar lehrer alter
menschen in tellow dass er richtig raus
gehauen mit der grafik und dann kriegt
er auch noch eben ein bisschen nähe der
krise hier ein bisschen trockenfutter
genau das stellen wir auch noch hin dann
ist dass man oft ganz schön bist doch
nicht mehr so hungrig und damit ich auch
sagen meine lieben freunde in der zeit
wo ballack gerade seinen essen ganz toll
verspeist das war's mit dieser folge
nintendo datei gerade bei ganz schön
langsam wieder wenn es euch gefallen hat
und ihr noch einen dritten teil interner
ort balu weil sie so legst du dich denn
jetzt das ist doch wenn ihr noch im
dritten teil von motiven
ich weiß nicht ob ich komm ich lasse
euch einfach mal mit balu alleine
tschüss
aha